Marvel's Phase 6 has not been revealed
yet however we do know a lot about a lot
of different projects that are going to
be announced for phase six what is going
on everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder I'm Warren Thompson and since the
reveal of the entirety of phase five and
some of Marvel's phase six fans have
been wondering what is in store for us
as far as projects are concerned for
phase six in the MCU unfortunately
Marvel Studio skipped out on some big
events this year like San Diego
Comic-Con where they typically announce
all of their big reveals for example
they announced the entirety of phase
five and some of phase six at sdcc last
year but sadly this year they did not
attend they do have some events coming
up however where they could give us a
sneak peek at phase six or simply just
give us some reveals in their entirety
plus not to mention Disney always does
investor meetings and quarterly earnings
reports where they have been known to
make some pretty decent reveals in the
past so what exactly will they be
revealing when they finally do get
around to telling us what phase six is
actually going to be luckily for us we
actually know a great deal about what is
is going to be included in Phase 6 both
movies and shows so we'll break down
everything that we know about facex and
what these projects are going to be and
could possibly going to be both
confirmed and rumored in this video and
of course if you want to stay up to date
on the MCU be sure to subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss out on any of
the latest MCU news and if you subscribe
and leave a comment down below you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items we pick one winner at the end of
each month and the winner gets to pick
one item from a new Fantastic Four movie
to an Avengers film to a possible new
X-Men movie fans are really excited
about phase six however in regards to
the X-Men Marvel Studios has a pretty
specific plan for them but we'll talk
about that at the end when Marvel
Studios originally revealed phase six at
San Diego Comic-Con in 2022 they
revealed 11 slots for phase six now they
actually did fill three of these slots
with the Fantastic Four with Avengers
King Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars so
only eight slots were left unknown now
to this day most most of us believe that
Marvel Studios didn't really have any
intention on sharing any of phase six
however a day before San Diego Comic-Con
a few of the titles for some upcoming
projects got released and two of those
titles were the New Avengers films
literally a day before we found out that
the next Avengers film would be called
the King Dynasty and the one after that
would be secret Wars so in order to
control the leaks we believe that Disney
just came out and announced it since
they were already out there so they kind
of beat everybody to the leaks and they
threw in the Fantastic Four since Kevin
fagiardi announced the Fantastic Four
was in development just giving us a
little something but we still believe
that they didn't really have true plans
on revealing phase six at that Comic-Con
just phase five but of course we are not
complaining and in the meantime they
have revealed a lot of other projects
that are going to be coming to the MCU
so of some insiders so let's break down
what we know now of course there are
movies and shows that have been
confirmed by Marvel just don't have a
release date yet but we know Phase 5
schedule we know everything in Phase
five so if it's not coming in phase 5
it's coming in phase six for example
Wonder Man we know that there's going to
be a Wonder Man Disney Plus show coming
well phase five is packed so far so
unless they're gonna slide that into
phase five somewhere in which they
haven't even begun production on it yet
so I doubt it so it's coming in phase
six and they've already cast for Wonder
Man Yaya Abdul Mateen the second is
going to be playing Simon Williams now
this project is going to be a little bit
different than the projects that we've
seen so far it's kind of going to be
like one division was at first it's kind
of going to be satire so it's going to
be interesting to see a show that is
also going to be a satire from Marvel
Studios another one that is confirmed is
armor Wars now originally this was
supposed to be a Disney Plus show and
was scheduled for phase five however
things have changed it is now a movie
and is most likely now coming out in
phase six since they haven't even
started pre-production on it yet however
we do know now that Roadie who of course
is going to be the main character in
armor Wars has been a scroll since
Captain America Civil War when he got
got hurt so it's going to be really
interesting to see how this movie plays
out and see the repercussions of that we
also have a confirmed wakanda Okoye
series coming Ryan coogler is coming
back to direct this series and based off
of everything that we've heard it is
going to take place in phase six now
I've heard some people talk about a
black panther 3. I do not expect a black
panther 3 to happen in the Multiverse
Saga I think if we get a black panther 3
it's coming in Phase 7 or phase eight so
if you've heard anything about a black
panther 3 I wouldn't hold your breath
and then of course we have Spider-Man 4.
this is confirmed and it has been
confirmed by Sony and by Tom Holland
himself what's interesting is that
Marvel and Sony both actually confirmed
they were working on Spider-Man 4
already about two weeks after Spider-Man
no way home but of course things can
change so it's really nice to know that
it's still on track and it was in
pre-production before the strikes
happened they had met several times they
were talking about the story Tom Holland
said he liked it and then unfortunately
the strikes happened and that shut that
down but be rest assured Spider-Man 4 is
happening and it is is coming in phase
six most likely between Avengers Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars it could come
before Kang Dynasty but from what some
insiders have said it looks like it's
going to come after Kang Dynasty but
there is a really big movie coming
before Kang Dynasty and that is Doctor
Strange 3. reports from insiders have
told us that this movie is confirmed to
be happening and basically Marvel
Studios confirmed this as well with the
post-credits scene for Multiverse of
Madness where CLIA shows up and says hey
you caused an incursion we're gonna go
fix it and Doctor Strange basically just
says cool let's go and they go and
that's going to play a big role in
Doctor Strange three the incursions that
are happening and the role that doctor
strange plays in both causing them and
fixing them now apparently Doctor
Strange 3 is going to lead us into
Avengers King Dynasty and that makes
sense because in Kang Dynasty The
Avengers are most likely going to lose
so Doctor Strange 3 is going to be about
strange trying to stop and fix
incursions from happening but then after
King Dynasty the whole Multiverse is
basically going to explode so this is
going to be a huge movie for phase six
and and like I said should come out
before King Dynasty leading right into
it another big one is going to be Shang
Chi 2. we know that the tin rings are
most likely some type of King Technology
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
basically confirmed this for us as well
as Kamala Khan's bangle but more on her
in a bit shangshi 2 was actually
confirmed about when the movie was
released and in fact the director of
shangchi Dustin Daniel Gretchen is going
to be directing King Dynasty so it would
make sense for Xiang Chi 2 to come out
before Kang Dynasty or possibly right
after since Dustin Daniel handled
chongqi and now is doing King Dynasty it
would make sense for him to do shangchi
too and since all of the stories are
really connected it could work both ways
either right before or right after but
Marvel Studios has confirmed this they
confirmed shangchi 2 is going to be
happening and a big one that we've heard
about recently is Thor 5. recently in an
official Thor love and thunder special
booklet Taiko watichi talked about what
his future plot details would be fourth
or five and also Chris Hemsworth said
that he is of course down to come back
provided that the tone be different for
Thor and the character have growth which
is what taikuichiti wanted as well
speaking about the character growth and
obviously since Thor is still around in
the MCU and has recently come in contact
with a cosmic entity we're assuming that
he's going to play a pretty big role in
secret Wars possibly even making his
return for Avengers King Dynasty as well
and in a battle for the universe it's
definitely good to have the god of
thunder on your side speaking of our MCU
Legacy Avengers it's been rumored for a
long time now and reported by insiders
that we are going to be getting a World
War Hulk movie and it does seem like it
is going to be coming in phase six in
fact Captain America Brave New World and
the Thunderbolts should set this movie
up now these movies are in Phase five
but again the phase Five schedule is
already so packed I don't really see
where they could work this in Phase five
so it should be coming in phase six we
know that there's going to be at least
one other Hulk in Captain America Brave
New World and that of course is going to
be red Hulk we also know from She-Hulk
that Hulk now has a son Scar and he is
here on Earth and sends Captain America
Brave New World is going to be
experimenting more with super soldier
serum we're expecting even more hulks to
show up now this isn't a classic World
War Hulk story obviously but this story
seems to be based off of multiple hulks
being on our Earth on our world and
seems to be setting things up for a Hulk
battle then we have the eternals number
two there's been a lot of talk about
this recently and I definitely think
this is still going to be made by Marvel
Studios however at this point in time
we're not really sure if it's going to
be in phase six or phase seven it would
make sense for it to be in phase six and
then deal with the celestials who of
course would then deal with Kang since
the celestials are basically in charge
of a universe and Kang is going about
destroying universes it would make sense
for them to get involved however the
story of the eternals does seem to be a
very secluded story so we're not sure if
that's going to have room in phase six
so they go the celestial route and the
impact that King is having definitely in
phase six but if they plan to take it a
different way which they might we might
have to wait till phase seven but they
did set up Harry Styles as Star Fox and
pip Patrol was there as well so they
definitely have plans for eternals too
then I've been hearing talk about Miss
Marvel season 2 and this I would say
would make sense if we weren't about to
see Kamala Khan again in the Marvels
obviously the Bengal that Kamala Khan
has seems to be some type of King
Technology however they are going to be
addressing this somewhat at least in the
Marvels she's one of the main characters
she's one of the stars of the movie so
the Marvels essentially is Miss Marvel
season 2. we haven't really heard
anything about a Miss Marvel season 2 so
I definitely don't think that is
happening in phase six however people
love Aman villani as Miss Marvel so I'm
sure there'll be a season two but I
think that's going to be after the
events of Avengers Secret Wars and
that's a lot of projects that we know
for phase six there are a few projects
like some special presentations like a
Nova one or a Silver Surfer one that are
kind of unsure right now but for the
most part that is pretty much our phase
six those are a lot of projects that we
have confirmed termed hopefully there
are a few more that they throw in there
that surprise us but those are the big
ones that are going to be coming now we
didn't mention the X-Men because there
isn't going to be an official X-Men
movie until phase seven possibly even
phase 8 if they decide to build up the
individual mutants one by one and then
eventually have an X-Men film The X-Men
film could be the very last film of
phase seven or it could be in Phase 8
somewhere that doesn't mean that we're
not going to see X-Men in the MCU until
phase seven in fact we are going to see
them they're just going to be from other
universes these will be the old Legacy
Fox X-Men characters we already have
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine coming back
there's talks of Patrick Stewart's
Professor X pretty much actually the
entire original cast from holly berry to
Ian McKellen James Marsden the Cyclops
the original cast plus Magneto and maybe
a couple other villains we'll see them
in secret Wars and it sounds like we're
gonna see pretty much all of them in
Deadpool 3 but as far as a new X-Men
team in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that's gonna come after the Multiverse
Saga I would love for for Marvel Studios
to surprise us with an X-Men film or a
movie about some specific mutants but I
don't think it's gonna happen but phase
six already sounds pretty dang good but
let us know your thoughts about it in
the comments down below do you like it
do you not like it what would you rather
see and what are you most excited about
leave all your thoughts in the comments
down below please don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news of
course you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf
foreign